[Music]
[Applause]
bailey johnson covers high school sports
for the columbus dispatch and she joins
us now
first of all bailey thanks for joining
us
uh being familiar with the columbus area
myself i had not heard of an actual
campus a high school called bishop
sycamore so uh is there an actual campus
a high school called bishop sycamore in
the columbus area there is not as far as
we're aware they do not have a campus or
a practice facility or
really anything tangible at all they
practice in a variety of indoor
facilities that they rent out for
a day at a time and that's pretty much
it
how did this happen that this is a
school that played i think six games
last year didn't win any of these games
and then next thing you know they're
playing
a great football team
on espn national tv
yeah it's still a little bit unclear how
the game came to be scheduled espn has
told us that it was scheduled by paragon
marketing group um and it's a little bit
unclear how paragon got connected with
the guys over at bishop sycamore my
understanding is there's another
scheduling company in the mix that sort
of connected bishop sycamore with img i
know they played last year at the end of
sycamore season last year they played
img so there's clearly some sort of
connection there to begin with but
frankly it's all still a little bit of a
mystery how they actually ended up
playing this football game when they
clearly had no business doing it are
these high school players
no
most of them are not
are they so they're over 18
i have been told that the majority of
them are at least 19 or 20 if not older
than that
but is that a crime
like if if i think we've seen this
before where you have uh there was a
high school player who was like 28 years
of age came in and was dominating high
school basketball but
you're playing against minors i i don't
know
what charges these coaches are facing to
begin with but i don't know if that's
criminal as well
my understanding is that it isn't but
you'd certainly think that it would be
to have them playing minors i know there
are other club teams in certainly the
columbus area and i imagine around the
country because that's really what they
are they're not a school they're a club
team at this point of
a bunch of guys just trying to play
football
there are definitely questions about how
that works with the fact that most of
them are not under the age of 18 and
frankly the more concerning part is that
some of them are and
should be getting a high school
education right now that they're not
getting
uh the coach what can you tell me about
the head coach
roy johnson is the head coach or it's
possibly andre peterson they kind of
switch back and forth on which one of
them is truly in charge um
we know that roy johnson has done this
before he ran an academy called cof
academy here in columbus a couple years
ago that ended up getting shut down
and it just kind of popped back up again
same people new name as bishop sycamore
this feels like a scam
is it is yeah
pretty much yeah
but what are they what are they getting
out of this what are they what are these
coaches trying to pull off here
well they're trying to and they do have
an admiral mission if they were
accomplishing it correctly they're
trying to take kids who are from maybe
disadvantaged backgrounds or
need help getting to college and playing
college football and they're trying to
help them but the overall impression is
they just don't really know what they're
doing and are probably doing more harm
than good have you reached out to
parents of these kids who are playing
for bishop sycamore
i've spoken to a parent whose son left
the program over the summer after
originally joining them at the beginning
of the spring
and what did they say
he said it all sounded good in the
beginning his son graduated from a
school here in columbus and was looking
to take a prep year to get better offers
after kovid sort of didn't allow him to
go to the camps he thought he would get
to go to
so they signed on with sycamore he was
going to be the starting quarterback
they were going to build a team around
him and then just
nothing ever materialized uniforms they
went on the camp circuit and left hotels
unpaid all around the country and
just all turned out to be quite shady
and they left at the end of the summer
do they have a game scheduled that
they're still going to play
they do as far as i know every game that
has been on their schedule which
includes they're supposed to play this
coming friday and i believe it's
tennessee they're supposed to play a
couple teams in ohio they're supposed to
play a team in texas and as far as i
know all of those games are still on as
scheduled but don't explain this to me
though bailey that they had a game was
it 48 hours prior to the game on espn
yes they played friday night in
pennsylvania
how did
how does this happen
no like nobody's nobody's monitoring
this like it's one thing for it to
happen but it's another thing that you
end up on espn
against a great team
yeah coaches are
they're our coaches are really wonderful
salesmen i can tell you that i listened
to them for three hours on a twitter
conversation yesterday and they
could sell a used car to a used car
salesman but i mean it's unbelievable
honestly what they've gotten away with
here so far they told us that only 12 to
15 of the players played in both games
and they only played maybe a few snaps
in the first quarter and then played in
the second half that type of thing but
from what we've seen on the tape from
both games that's not the case
this is crazy
and and then you're hearing these horror
stories that you know maybe they were
stealing food because they didn't have
food there's a gofundme page
uh not paying hotel bills it you know
feels like somebody's going to jail here
bailey
it does it very much does i don't know
of anything at this point but i can only
imagine that investigations are coming
because especially with the kids they
have that are under the age of 18 they
have a obligation to be providing them
an education that they're not getting
what's the local uh reaction in columbus
a lot of people it's kind of split
between
yeah we knew these guys were shady this
isn't surprising and people who have
never heard of them
a lot of people really didn't know this
was happening and the people who did are
like yeah we know roy johnson he's done
this before this doesn't shock us that
the scam blew up on national tv is there
an address
do they list an address for the school
the address that's registered with the
state for last school year which by the
way as far as we're aware they're not
registered with the state for this
coming school year um the address that's
listed is for an indoor training
facility about 15 minutes outside of
downtown and the people at that training
facility have told us they come in maybe
once a month to use the weight room for
a little bit
good luck with this bailey sounds like a
plum assignment here of trying to
untangle this uh evil web here you have
with and i don't think there is an
actual bishop named sycamore is there i
i went to catholic grade school i i
didn't pay attention but i don't know if
there's a is it the patron of lost
causes like is there a bishop sycamore
here bailey
as far as i know there is not i did see
a tweet from andre peterson one of the
leaders where he said the bishop
basically means that he's the overseer
and he's the overseer of the program so
i think it comes from him somehow
um
that doesn't sound good bailey thanks
for joining us thank you for having me
that's bailey johnson covers high school
sports for the columbus dispatch